[Music]
welcome to science in the hands of
scientists I'm Carl Zimmer and this
afternoon we're going to have a
conversation about how science happens
you know we have to bear in mind science
is not something that happens in the
abstract people do science and so these
are not you know gods who are impervious
to the forces that shape us they're
human like the rest of us and they deal
with all sorts of factors that everybody
else does it can be everything from
pressures to to get a job to get funding
there can be internal biases there can
be the the thirst for glory there are
all sorts of things that can shape how
scientists decide to do science and what
they choose to do and that's what we're
going to be talking about this this
afternoon we're going to have an open
discussion about the scientific process
and how it works from the classroom to
the lab to the journal and then out into
the rest of the world so let me start
now to introduce our panelists
our first guest this afternoon she is a
principal investigator at the tuff
Center for regenerative and
developmental biology
please welcome Danny Spencer Adams our
next guest is the KDI Ronnie professor
of philosophy at City College of New
York he works on the philosophy of
science and the nature of pseudoscience
please welcome Massimo Pigliucci
[Applause]
our third guest today is a distinguished
writer in residence at New York
University's Arthur Carter journalism
Institute he's the co-founder of
retraction watch full disclosure I have
written about his work for the New York
Times
so please welcome ivan Oransky and last
but certainly not least our final guest
is the editor-in-chief of Scientific
American she also oversees the
journalists both at Scientific American
and at the nature journals please
welcome Mariette - Kristina so now that
I have you all out let's just start by
just kind of talking about how you make
a scientist and maybe Danny I could
start with you I mean so you have a lab
and you are bringing in students at
Tufts who want to be scientists so how
do you take them from being students to
people who are going to do science in
the 21st century I would describe it
mostly as like an internship or or you
most of it is just being thrown right in
here do this and there's a lot of
supervising teaching specific things
specific skills specific techniques
protocols and then there's the other
it's more of a meta kind of approach
where you have to teach really the you
could call it scientific thinking you
called the scientific method but really
the idea that science is simply one way
of learning things and it's it's been a
very very powerful very good way of
learning things and it's in some ways
not not human like okay I don't want to
say in here man I don't wanna say
superhuman but humans and I'm very much
looking forward to the rest of my kind
of talk about this but humans have
what's called confirmation bias and we
tend to
recognize and remember the things that
confirm what we already believe and I
just throw this out most people if you
think about the newspapers you read
you're not most of us me included I'm
not looking for new information I'm
looking for
confirmation for what I already believe
and you can say I knew it I knew it yeah
I knew that was he shouldn't have been
elected no names and I think that one
really useful way to think about science
as a way of learning is it's about
overcoming confirmation bias so it's
about phrasing a question in a way that
allows you to ignore what you believe or
even say okay here's my idea now I'm
going to try and prove myself wrong and
I can't think of any other way of
learning or thinking where that's what
you do where you say here's my terrific
idea and now I'm going to try and kill
it
and so learning the intellectual skills
of thinking that way and asking
questions that way and controls are all
about proving that what you thought was
going to happen wouldn't happen that it
was actually the injection you did or it
was actually because the air conditioner
was on or it was Thursday and and I
think that that that is what makes it so
powerful is that it's it's about
overcoming confirmation bias so that you
can see what's there rather than what
you were expecting do you find that you
have to kind of to push them further
when they're sort of satisfied that they
absolutely done enough to try to prove
themselves wrong what no looks like I'm
right yeah absolutely it's it's there's
there's you know it's crushing its ego
crushing you come in and you're so
excited and you're gonna get to have
wonderful conversations and and there's
fantastic questions and you're gonna
find the answers and you're gonna change
the world and and first of all it's not
like that it takes a very long time
but you have to constantly say alright
how would you disprove that
how would you disprove that what's the
proper control how you know that you
know how are you going to interpret it
if you get one of these three possible
results and what are you going to do if
you get something that you didn't
predict at all it's theirs it's you have
to teach that and the only way to teach
that that we know of at this point is
simply to do it so students come in and
you know and you get them started and
then you say okay no that's wrong and
that's wrong and that's wrong and that's
wrong and and there's a there's a saying
if you're not failing most of the time
you're not working hard enough and
that's a that's a hard thing to get
students through absolutely yeah and and
Massimo you you have a long career not
only as a philosopher but but as a
scientist and have you know you know
train your own so in I was in
evolutionary biology I tend to agree
with with most of what you just said I
would even go even further in terms of
I'm a little more pessimistic about how
the whole thing works so ideally
actually I think that a lab works a lot
like a renaissance place where you go
and learn from little Angelo from you
know whatever it is right so a workshop
you come in and you learn because you
are in constant contact and interaction
with not only the master that will be
the PI the you know the principal
investigator of the lab but in Fatt also
the people that have been there for a
long time so senior gotta be students or
postdocs or things like that right so
you are immersed in an intellectual
environment and and you're doing things
every day and that's how you learn how
to do science but I honestly don't think
actually that individually we can as
much as we it's a good idea to be aware
of it and try I don't think we can
individually overcome a confirmation
bias the way it happens most of the time
is precisely because the rest of the
people in the lab but you could the
principal investigator tell you no
that's not gonna work
you know why don't you think about it
that way and of course who does that for
the piane who watch watches the Watchmen
that's the peer review outside of the
lab right so you have the PI himself or
herself has to get grant proposals
approved those have to go through people
have the process peer review even if
they are proved in the research gets
done then you have to publish the
results and yes it is ego crushing I
mean it's rejection over and over and
over and you just have to grow a thick
skin and deal with it but that's the way
you learn about doing it so so when you
when you look at the you know the cohort
of new scientists you know coming out
you know freshly minted PhDs and 2017
you know what's it like for them
starting out now in science as opposed
to 1997 it's some response is the same
it's the excitement is still there and
it's like it's a great time for science
for biology for physics for other
disciplines but at the same time you're
also very conscious these days that you
know making a career in academia it's
not it's not easy number of people I
mean typically when we advertise for one
position there is like 150 applicants
easily and I guarantee you a lot of them
are actually qualified for that position
so it gets you know that you get into a
period of possibly several years where
you go from one postdoc to the other or
from one urgent position to the other
and if you're lucky you're actually
gonna make it by the mid you know the
time you're in the mid 30s or something
into a beginning of a tiny a tenure
track so things are changing in that
sense the job market in the sciences has
Gunung has gotten worse over decades I
mean that the real peak period that was
in the 1960s and the early seventies
where you could just go out and get a
job it hasn't been like that for a while
and it's increasingly less so but we
also have a lot of talent we have a lot
of people that I have you know you do it
because you have you're excited battery
you you really have the you know one
experience the joy of being a scientist
in the lab but you don't do it for the
money because it doesn't really pay that
well and does you don't do it for the
benefits because those come very late
your career you have to sacrifice a
number of things you do it because you
love it so I haven't Mariette I mean
you're you're kind of more on sort of
the outside looking in on this culture
of science and I'm curious if
you see differences now and what it's
like for scientists to be starting out
and launching their careers in science
now as opposed to like when you start it
being journalists I don't know which one
of you wants to jump in just I can start
and then Mariette will probably say
something smarter and more scientific
than I will is that you know I was just
like if I may for ten seconds and just
say what Danny was saying about and I
think about confirmation bias a lot
everything that you said about
scientists and how you really ideally
want to wake up every morning going how
can I prove myself wrong
well journalists are supposed to do that
too and you know I I'm not gonna claim
that I do that I wake up usually and you
know check Facebook but you know you you
want to wake up and you need an editor
you need someone who's saying well wait
a second you know yeah you have that
document but that document doesn't
really say what you think so I just want
to reflect on that for a second I I
think that there are two I wouldn't call
them changes necessarily but they've
sort of accelerated and I'd be
interested to hear what others think
about this but they were sort of there's
sort of two phenomena that I think have
accelerated one is what I would refer to
as a sort of metric as métro cessation
right so everything is now measured and
this is true in all walks of life it's a
sort of if you'll forgive me a little
bit of nut philosophy exactly the
political science or of a neoliberal
idea that so you know we can measure
everything and so that includes
measuring impact of research it includes
something called the impact factor so
how do you describe how you measure the
impact of somebody's study so how do you
know often you know what a lot of it is
based on and I'm not sort of here to
defend this but just to say that this is
what happens is how often are other
scientists citing that work so if a tree
falls in the forest and no one hears it
you know did it really fall if a paper
is published and no one cites it does it
really matter and again I'm not
condoning that but that is what matters
and so you turn that into a number you
turn into a number of numbers actually
an ever-growing sort of forest of
numbers where you actually have some
impact factor so the number of times on
average I'm simplifying here that a
given our articles in a given journal or
published and a lot of people and I
kind of him in this camp a bit say that
this has really had a dramatic effect on
science and not necessarily in a good
way because everyone is pushed to
publish in these high impact factor
journals and so they publish a lot of
really good science but it also what it
means is that tenure committees
promotions anyone who sort of helps you
to get ahead or is what you need to get
through thinking ahead peer review
committees you know Boston was talking
about peer review they all are looking
for these numbers they're not
necessarily reading the entire paper
anymore which is what you would hope
they would do but they're just looking
at well is it in this journal or that
journal or what have you and the other
thing very quickly that I think is
happening that alongside this and really
feeding into it as well is that there
was a blip and and now it's sort of
looking more and more like a blip from
1998 to 2003 if you look at the doubling
so the NIH budget and that's not excuse
me
they main funder of biomedical research
in the u.s. exactly the and this was a
good thing for science it meant that
there were more it was more funding
obviously twice as much funding over
that period of time but that stopped and
so in fact you could argue and if you
look at inflation the amount of funding
federal funding for the NIH has declined
and yet all of those graduate students
postdoc trainees well they were all
working somewhere because labs just
staffed up it was like some kind of boom
it really was a boom well for the so for
the past whatever it is 14 years now
we've gotten many men even more than we
had and it wasn't so good as Massimo
pointed out since you know whether it's
the 60s are you know early 70s and so
you had more and more people competing
all needing to get all these numbers and
lo and behold we've we're seeing a lot
more competition and that a little bit
of competition is a really good thing
too much competition can really harm you
thanks very much by the way I've been
fascinating just to listen so far for me
absolutely wonderful so I have two
things I would like to add just
reflecting on the ideas of confirmation
bias and on increasing competition and
on impact factor on the two areas so
first of all I think a thing that we
often don't recognize is a Publishing's
role in the second
both at the popular level so the
Scientific American level where I'm
editor-in-chief one way we can either
foster haste in publication or not as
how do we jump on this week salt is bad
for you this week it's good for you you
know you can can we take the longer view
provide context not be slaves to the
embargo system the system where you know
we all agree that a paper is going to
come out a period of time from now and
then journalists like me and like Ivan
we get a few days head notice to and we
the idea is that we will we will you
know we will all publish our stories at
the same time and we'll have had some
some some equal access to the experts to
do that without haste but also comes
with a whole host of other challenges
which we may we may or may not come come
on to later so that's that's one aspect
so mass publications like like
Scientific American and then the
journals themselves how do we you know I
I am NOT a journal editor although I
work at a large publishing company
Springer Nature which which publishes
2,000 around 2 journals and including
some of the biggest ones like nature
including some of the ones with the very
high impact factor very selective
journals like nature and the nature of
branded titles and how do we set
standards there that in effect slow down
that haste to publish that enable a
little more checking and accuracy like
reproducibility checklists like checking
methods and protocols like is supporting
the research community so those
pressures that be like Maximo are
calling honor or noticing or are
somewhat supported and slowed down a
little more and then I want to set the
lens a tiny bit more broadly outside of
publishing so how do we as a society
look at science and treat it do we you
know jump for the latest headline or do
we start with our kids when they're very
very small because researchers like
Alison Gopnik will point out your old
Bourne researchers and you don't have to
believe me just watch any kid and a high
chair dropping different things off to
see how they fall and they bounce or
whatever so you're all born
experimenting but over time in schools
we're taught through a series of classes
that science is a set of received wisdom
and not something that you try and fail
because you know
while watching my own girls one now and
in college one in high school every
every experiment they take in every
science class has the right answer so
this is kind of how the math society is
left so I I encourage us to look at
those two lenses you know one is the
role of publishing in the ecosystem and
the broader role of society at large I
have to say as a journalist when I was
starting out the there came a point and
it took a little while for me to to
actually appreciate how much of the work
of a scientist was filling out paperwork
to get the money to do science and I
like I just sort of thought like well
somehow like the money just sort of like
shows up in a box or something and then
the scientist does the science you know
I mean when you read a you know you read
a biography Hyde Stein you don't read
him filling out an application in the
National Science Foundation you know you
you want to know how he came over the
equals mc-squared but I just remember
like I think there was one the one time
it really hit me I went to interview a
scientist a biologist like a leading
evolutionary biologist and they come
into his office and he's like hold on I
can't talk with you just yet and he was
on a conference call with these
co-authors who all wanted to get this
grant and they were trying to figure out
why it was that there there there the
essay they wrote to get this money
didn't fit on one page like there was
something wrong with the font and they
couldn't figure out what was wrong in
the font you know because they had like
two or three words sort of spilling off
the end of this PDF no my god why that
you know and if we don't get this all on
one page there's no chance we're gonna
get this money there's no chance we're
gonna be making the screen inside I'm
just looking at them like I I didn't
come here for this and I had to wait
like 20 minutes for them to like fix the
frigging font and apply for the grant
and and then we could get to the science
and I'm just sort of wondering like I
mean that's the sort of stuff we tend
not to report on but as much obviously
like really I mean that must be a big
part of what goes on in terms of like
your time and then also what how does it
affect what you're going to decide to
study yeah it's it's
very frustrating part of it and it's
something that I do wish more people
knew about because I mean your tax
dollars put me through school you
trained me and I'm trained to be in the
lab and how to ask a question how to
design an experiment and I probably
spend I probably spend fifty percent of
my time writing the same thing over and
over again changing the font changing
the format making sure this thing is
filled out and that's filled it and and
you know we have a rule never ever
update your software within one week of
the due date because it will you will
get messed up don't send from a Mac to a
PC because it'll come back wrong and
it's it's very frustrating to do that
and the bigger the lab so the the more
productive the lab should be and can be
and is the more time the p.i is probably
spent observe a peer sensor principal
investigator and that's the big
scientists in the lab that's then the
person who gets all the credit even
though the work is done by many people
60 to 70 percent of the time is spent
doing the paperwork writing the story
and on top of that so to the community
and I think the journalistic community
as well is is aware of these issues and
is is trying thinks are there ways that
we can get around this and and for
example the journal development which is
the big journal in my field has recently
announced that you can submit it in any
form you want and they will deal with it
they've decided that reviewers are
capable of reading a paper even if it's
a different font than the one they it's
so that's great that's a really nice
thing other journals are working there
there are some journals now that are
connected up so that if you don't get
into the highest impact one you can have
it exactly you can have it submitted to
the next one down without doing anything
else you can just be saving your time so
it's yeah it's been on site exactly so
so trying to mitigate some of this
silliness that we spend our time on
but even when you spend all this time I
mean if you look at the percentage of
applications that are accepted and lead
to a grant right yeah I mean that's the
other problem is is limited there are
limited funds and the competition
competition is is intense how does that
affect the science that you decide to do
so the big granting agency the National
Institutes of Health of which there's 18
I think and then and by the way the more
important problem I think is National
Science Foundation so NIH is is
biomedical NSF is everything else
everything else and its budget is very
small compared to NIH s but you so right
now I think in my field it the the
places where I apply for money you have
to be in the top four or five percent of
you know the your peers were people who
will understand what you're trying to do
rank it and then they decide and you
have to be in the top four percent and
if you're not you will lose you know
that's it there goes your salary and
that's hard you're competing with people
across the entire nation and to stay in
the top four percent it's one thing to
be an A student in high school it's
quite another to be the only a the one
you know one a in thousands and that's
so what you tend to do is you you these
these agencies what they do is they put
out these things called RFA's requests
for applications and there's these are
where they're saying all right Congress
has decided that what we should spend
our money on this year is mapping the
brain and so they'll say they'll set
aside okay we're gonna set aside fifty
million dollars for people who want to
map the brain and then they put out one
of these RFA's and you go to the website
and you think well okay I'm a brain
person I'm gonna go and I'm gonna find
out is there money out there for doing
this thing well it turns out there is it
turns out that some Congress person got
put in there that what really matters is
this part of the brain you know if
you're studying the cerebellum you've
got a much better chance but if
you're studying the cortex we're just
lunged at this year so yeah you might
very well switch and and so it ends up
ultimately being guided by Congress it's
up to Congress to say this is what's on
the agenda now this is what we think is
important and the scientists are
becoming more savvy about this and
there's a lot more scientists now going
to Washington and we now get trained and
how to lobby for science because that it
loops back around to what you're going
to be able what what passion are you
gonna be able to follow your passion in
the direction that you as the trained
person think is the best direction to go
or are you going to have to fit it into
something that came down from Congress
how do you I mean how do you think about
how this is this thing this fierce
competition that affects the papers that
get published and then do you see that
do you see an influence happening there
there's a couple things that I'd like to
ask what you guys have been talking
about for the last few minutes so at NSF
in my field I'm working about the
funding rate is five to six percent that
means that when I was an active P I I
had to write a grant proposal every
semester and two out of three will
probably be rejected which still was
much higher than me but that was
frustrating that was a lot of time then
you yes you're right you learn also two
out of lobby that's it
another chunk of time that goes away
from the science and will do something
that you were not really set up to do to
begin with but we have to realize that
there's a couple things going on first
of all this is actually rather be new
and also it's not unavoidable because
there are other ways of doing things so
it's new in the sense that NSF and all
the major federal agencies were created
after World War two and that's why
Einstein didn't have to do that sort of
stuff or board didn't have to do that
sort of stuff because they were simply
not around even even after they were
created initially there was actually a
flood of money after the war was the you
know in terms of economic expansion
there was all you know science
especially physics at
a lot of cachet and so they were just
getting money period
the as you said when you introduce me
I'm the KDE Rani professor of philosophy
at City College well KDE Rani was hired
you know like four decades ago at City
College because Einstein met him at
Princeton and he wrote to City College
and say I like this guy you should iron
and was hired that I guarantee you
that's not gonna happen to that that's
just not gonna happen
or not it'd be a good decision but
nonetheless so all of these is actually
fairly new and it's gotten much much
worse over the last sort of twenty to
thirty years or so but there's also some
very bizarre ways that actually typical
of the American system you don't
necessarily find in other countries in
the world even even in other Western
countries so NSF for instance for a long
time has concentrated more and more
money on a smaller smaller number of
laboratories they go for the big
projects they go to from the big things
one of the reasons is as you were saying
a minute ago because that sells to
Congress and I can tell you a story that
occurred a few years ago that I thought
was hilarious and at the same time
extremely sad so I was invited to a NSF
retreat with a bunch of other ecologist
and watering biologists and they told us
look we want to give you big money but
the way to give you big money is to
attach it to some kind of big project
because otherwise Congress is not gonna
do it and so they said you know try to
tell us you think about it for this
entire weekend think about the
equivalent in ecology of let's say an S
tronic Observatory or a satellite or
something like that or a particle
accelerator so let's say then we want to
give you not the usual five hundred
thousand six hundred thousand dollars
but you know thirty million dollars what
would you do with that and it was
hilarious because the answer was I could
hire two hundred postdocs this because
most of the working colleges field work
you know that I don't need an
observatory or a settler I do need of
whatever a lot of people in the field
you know doing the actual work but that
isn't the kind of thing that is selling
a project to Congress other countries do
it differently although unfortunately
more and more they're following the
American model because America is
capable of exporting a lot of good
things and then all the bad things and
the rest of the world somehow buys it so
Canada and most Europe for instance for
instance they do a different system
where they give smaller grants
to a much larger number of lamps and the
way it works is you write much smaller
proposals instead of a 15-page proposal
or NSF you have an you know three or
four pages proposal and all you have to
do is really to maintain a certain
publication record if you can show that
over the last three years you have
published you know a decent number of
papers in decent journals and then you
now have a new idea you want to proceed
in that direction they're gonna look at
anything yeah sure good enough that's
we're gonna give you the money and we'll
see how girls you know three years down
the road that's not the case for NSF NIH
anything like that so there are
different ways of structure in the
system and I think the part of the
problem is that of course the American
system is the one that does pump more
money than anybody else in in scientific
research and so we think of of science
in the way in which it's done in the
United States but it's not the only
model so what's your perspective yeah I
mean if it maybe pumps more money than
many others but it's sad fact about us
research is the funding overall has been
roughly static since the 1980s and down
and I actually get quite concerned I
like science that provides solutions as
much as the next person because yeah we
you know one of the challenges and why
Nobel Prizes take so long as basic
research may take decades to then get to
applied and surely nobody truly Einstein
who was mentioned earlier today and this
is a this is something that maybe a lot
of folks in the audience have heard
already certainly when he was working on
relativity theories
it was never thinking about him being
applied in my iphone with my GPS which
of course we do every day without
thinking but even the iPhones have a
couple of dozen innovations in them
themselves and that nobody thought of
would be applied later on so it's one
challenge I see some interesting models
I also like our places where in Europe I
think there's some great leadership on
this funding the researcher rather than
the research projects which i think is a
how how would that work so a researcher
has demonstrated through some initial
work over time that they they have some
interesting lines of inquiry that they
will be pursuing and they get a block of
money for maybe five years at a time
instead of one study or the next study
of the next study I think that's quite
interesting I think that's a one way to
look at it another is for the
publication piece of it you might
decide that the publication will be okay
as long as the methods and statistical
accuracy that you're going to use for
analyses are agreed beforehand and one
of our relatively newer journals nature
human behavior is looking at this sort
of model as well so that the researchers
know when they've submitted something
they can kind of a pre peer review
almost that tells them that when they
get when they get done through it they
will get to publish something so models
like that and also I'm thinking broad
MIT and Harvard and how they have staff
scientists to help work and remove some
of that admin burden that many of the
researchers shouldering you mentioned
about about grants and you you know
listening to people as they're fussing
through the grants I think the long
story short of it is that there are so
many elements that challenge research
and we're going to have to take a kind
of a multi-pronged approach to solving
all of these various problems I want to
switch gears a little bit and Ivan maybe
you could tell us a little bit about a
retraction watch because I want to talk
about some of the things that with the
panel as a whole about some of the
things that you kind of you know expose
as you as you run this site so so why
you know as a journalist why would you
say hey you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna set up a website dedicated only to
retractions of scientific studies like
why why would you do that that's a great
question Karl if I had the answer I
probably wouldn't have started so Adam
Marcus is my co-founder he and I
launched retraction watch not quite
seven years ago now it'll be seven years
in August and to be honest the very the
basic idea there really two guiding
principles or sort of reasons why we
were interested in doing this in
particular Adam had been reporting on
attractions for a while I had been doing
the same but credit where credit's to he
had broken a couple big stories one
particular anesthesiology researcher who
ended up going to prison because of
scientific fraud was a very rare
phenomenon very rare event but that of
course grabbed everyone's attention in
fact I was a scientific American at the
time
and we reported on this after Adam did
and all that and so one and that sort of
speaks to the fact that often scientific
attractions maybe I'll just back up and
explain what they are sure because I
think that too many people including me
until that seven years ago wasn't quite
clear um this is sort of if you will the
and I'm gonna mix metaphors and I should
definitely not do this with Massimo here
but this is the sort of nuclear option
if you will of sign of self correction
or any kind of correction in science so
you're saying not only is was there a
problem with this this paper this fine
thing ever there's an error here but you
shouldn't trust it you shouldn't rely on
it at all you shouldn't decide it or if
you do cite it you should make it very
clear that's been retracted it is again
retracted from the literature withdrawn
from the literature guidelines say it
should still sit there in the literature
review marked really almost with a
scarlet letter
in fact puffin a red stamp says
retracted on and so there were that's
what her attraction is and what Adams
started seeing with these retractions
from this particular anesthesiologist
was Wow there's a great big story here
and as a journalist I mean there are
investigative journalists who I you know
admire and just want to be one one day
but really a demand I think of ourselves
as finding stories that are hiding in
plain sight and attractions are a great
example of that so here's a you know a
bunch of retraction they seem very
arcane why is this paper being retracted
and oh wait a second this guy's made up
all the data for 25 different studies so
if there's that line at the end of a lot
of Hollywood movies you know no animals
were harmed in the making of this film
and so it was sort of like that no
patients were harmed in the making of
this study because they weren't actually
any patients in this study so that's
sort of a different mistake so there was
that element but the other thing we
noticed was that the retraction notices
themselves is not a very transparent
process I mean the process is not
transparent the outcome is not
transparent so the retraction notices
themselves or either you know some of
them actually told you what happened but
a lot of them either they were sort of
mealy-mouthed they wouldn't really tell
you this whole story or they would
actually be wrong it would make
something sound like it was a an honest
error when in fact it was fraudulent and
it turns out we've now learned you're
you know a few years after we started
the blog that a the number of
attractions has dramatically increased
it's far outpaced
the amount of papers being published no
there's a rate of growth and then they
think in fact one you and I wonder times
we talk for the time as his better
studied came out showing that the number
of attractions went up tenfold from
about forty per year in 2002 four
hundred per year in 2010 this continued
to grow that's out of about one and a
half to two million papers so it's still
a very rare event and you know the other
thing that's happened is that we know
that now two-thirds of the mark due to
misconduct are due to fraud so there's a
sort of US federal definition of a fraud
and it is or misconduct size of
misconduct which is something that has
also been sort of exported to other
countries and a lot of a lot of
agreement on that but it's FFP is the
FFP is the what he called serve acronym
so it's falsification fabrication and
plagiarism plagiarism hopefully self
evident everywhere in the room but we
can talk later if it isn't but
falsification is you did an experiment
but it didn't go exactly the way you
think it should have gone to prove the
sort of whatever it is that you're
trying to prove
so you fudge the results a little bit
maybe you literally use it's Photoshop
and you take out the little band that
shouldn't have been there a little spa
then oh I'm sure that was just an error
you know the the lab tech didn't have
enough coffee that morning and so I'll
just erase that one that wasn't at one
the ultimate in confirmation bias it's
complete confirmation lies I know I was
right yes I'll just treat the photograph
just right and then the other half is
fabrication where you actually make it
up like this guy Scott Rubin did and so
that's the sort of triad we've seen a
lot of other things happening crazy
stories about people doing their own
peer review actually management appear
view to their own papers sure well
familiar with peer review it's the ideas
that has been done by a peer now I
happen to think that I'm careless so I
there are no ears but you actually are
supposed to have someone else do that
reflective property it's not so there
have been just about five hundred papers
retracted because people figured out a
way to either peer review the paper
themselves or have someone sort of do it
for them so that they could then peer
review their paper and not in the sort
of usual way that we all know that
happens but a directed way so
mariya what's your feeling on sort of
you know the issue with retracted papers
and you know perhaps as you know
reflecting these pressures we're talking
about ya know it certainly you know
acknowledging all all the pressures and
actually I just want to put in a you
know appraised for for retraction
watching for scientists who you know
let's not forget slants is a process I I
talked a little earlier about how we
sometimes in school and early school
years treated as a you know a series of
received wisdom bits of facts that
everybody knows and that that's always
true but actually one of the things
that's very wonderful about science is
that it tries to embrace its Corrections
and self Corrections and so on and and I
also thought listening to to your
excellent eye out line Ivan that a thing
we should mention it for for folks who
maybe not familiar is that you know the
fact that you can reproduce something
doesn't make it right and the fact that
you can't reproduce it doesn't make it
wrong there are lots of things that
happen in between problems with your
reagents problems with the techniques
with the methods used in a lab and this
is why you know III talked a little
earlier about what publishing outlets
like mine can help do for one thing that
in our you know in our journals they
remove the restrictions they used to
have on length of methods you were
talking about fitting a couple of words
on the page we used to have restrictions
and and now online they can be much
longer and provide more detail so other
researchers can can help provide that
course correct or correction by by
checking something or providing
protocols while providing the raw data
which we now increasingly hook to the
the figures that are in the papers as
well all of these help the scientific
communities police themselves in
addition to you know you're quite right
there's of course there is wrongdoing
I'm as Sciences ultimately done by units
we're all flawed every soften but there
are these larger factors at play as well
right but and even if even if people are
not committing fraud or misconduct or
fabrication I mean there's also the
issue of do you have have you know have
have your students challenged to
themselves enough you know or they said
like well I got I got the value I want
got
go publish you know rather than take
yeah known as P hacking right exactly
and so I mean do you see that as a
pressure like you know like I mean maybe
young scientists don't have the luxury
spending another year or two saying like
I don't think that's quite right let me
make sure that my results are good I a
couple of comments to some things I've
heard here one is that another one of
the perhaps unique things about science
is you don't have to be right how do you
so it slides meanders I love the title
of the salon you did and and an adjunct
to that point is that the way scientific
paper about scientific studies are
reported the structure of a scientific
paper an introduction a section that
describes how you did it a section that
describes what you got and then there's
a whole section called the discussion
where you put in what you think it means
and you may be wrong and that's fine
that's not the criterion the criterion
is did you do the right thing did you
answer did you do the right controls did
you use your techniques properly and the
results this was described to me when I
was a student as the results is that is
the part of the paper that will never
change when you did exactly what you
have said in the methods in material
section is supposed to be where you
provide enough detail that someone can
replicate it and then there's the
results that's what happened in that
situation on those days with those
reagents and there's a and it's one of
the things I think that makes these
papers very boring because you know
what's the fun part the fun part is what
does it mean what does it tell me how do
I interpret this but it's absolutely
critical and I'm not the person who's
gonna figure out how to do this but but
understood that's the stuff that gets
lost when you switch to journalism where
you need to have a headline where you
need to sell the paper and you have
exactly two inches for your headline and
and
it's but i but the point i wanted to
make is that this is the structure of
the paper that convention that tradition
is another one of the ways that
scientists police is it going to come
out right you you say here's what I did
and it's open game anybody who wants to
and who has the money in the equipment
can replicate it and disagree with you
and you have this whole section that's
your your opinion and it's separated out
and it says this is the editorial part
here's what happened here's the
editorial part and and we build on each
other we don't have one person who's
studied you know we have Newton and we
have these wonderful laws and and that's
great and he was wrong and it's he was
he was wrong when you try to then apply
them in other circumstances so but but
science meanders and science builds and
and of course you end up but you know
you want your grant you want your
headline you want those things but there
are so many little places built in to
try to keep us honest there's no
question of incentives and the
incentives can be structured again
differently right so for instance we
talked a lot about replication but of
course there is no incentive whatsoever
to replicate somebody else's results so
explain why wouldn't scientists want to
spend their time trying to replicate
what someone else did because there's
only the adventure right you know you
want to be the first one to get there
not the second one of the day not the
fourth one and you can't publish it and
usually you don't publish it why can't
you publish it because most journals
especially the high-impact journals want
the novel stuff the sexy stuff the
things that nobody's done before right
so even though that's slowly beginning
to change I mean there are some journals
would work except replications and but
those are not the ones that you build
your career you don't you don't become
famous as a scientist but I say yeah
yeah I check these other guys were
correct right nobody it just doesn't pay
to reverse as number 2 or 3 or 4 so
that's one thing the in terms of
incentive structure there's also the the
issue that the publish or perish sort of
culture arguably is all in there at
least since
well - but it has gone worse precisely
because there is a large number of
scientists a large number of June
ultimate guy folks for nature's about
2,000 acre
polishes mm right that's one published
right so the result of it is that you
know you were saying earlier if somebody
publishes a paper and nobody reads it or
cites it that you know what was that
well the thing that really opened my
eyes is a few years ago there was a
study that showed that of all the papers
published in major top biology journals
the really top-notch not journals one
third only is cited within five years
from publication that means two thirds
let's get like at it this is this
straight right two-thirds of top papers
in your published papers published in
top journals never get cited period
that's a lot of waste of money and
energy but it should psyche I mean
citation obviously there are many
alternative metrics as well absolutely
citation is important you know
publishers also do have places
increasingly now for publishing negative
results like scientific reports in my
own journal group will allowed on your
application to help support so it's
about that great point yeah so you can
change the structure of the of the
incentives or so one of the things that
would some people have including my
colleagues and I've been doing when we
get these 150 applications for instance
from young people postdocs great other
students they want a new job instead of
doing the bean-counting and say okay so
how many papers you you have we say okay
well that's nice you publish 20 papers
in the last five years now pick your top
three the ones you not that ones that
have been published at o'clock the best
three journals that top three the ones
you think you made an impact and I'll
read them and the rest I'm just gonna
ignore because it's just being counting
that I think big brings back a little
bit of quality into quality control into
instead of just doing the simple thing
it's like churning and and I mean Adam
and I have applauded efforts like that
because it actually gets back to let's
read the paper and let's say I
understand what are you and and who
cares what he's you're almost blind your
off to what journal it's in right with
all due respect nature and I mean you
nature Springer has every range top to
bottom in term but you know a range of
selective or perhaps less but and if I
can be just sort of dark for a second
than I and I just because to put things
in perspective you know we're talking
you know you're talking about you know
an American University I think in
Western Europe you see a lot of the you
know a lot of movements to do that and
Mary it was talking about some different
funding models that are I would argue
progressive in terms of that certain
parts of the world are going exactly in
the opposite direction so for example in
China you get a half salary bonus if you
publish in a journal with a certain
impact factor depends on your field or
what have you you know you get a paper
in nature you can never forget it I
think you they buy you a palace I'm
talking about you know a sort of
respectable okay yeah we're respectable
you can a paper in or just a respectable
Journal and you're gonna get six months
of salary right and you can keep hitting
that pinball you know I don't know if
that metaphor works anymore today but
you can keep hitting that you know as
many times I'm sure there's some limit
or what-have-you but the point is I mean
I like to think of myself as a fairly
you know I'm gonna do what's right and
sort of all the ethical person I gotta
tell you if I you know was offered the
opportunity and had to figure out a way
to do it I might sort of and even if I
thought well I'm still doing the right
thing
it's going to it's gonna clearly do
something and and every country has
somewhere on that spectrum and you know
even you know some for example in the UK
there's then it's changed a bit so this
is being maybe a little bit unfair but
they're these sort of framework exercise
exercise frameworks where you look at
the evaluation framework excuse me where
departments get more money if or your
your university gets more money from the
government if you have an average you
know impact factor and certain number of
papers and this sort of thing so I
applaud all of the efforts of people are
making to get away from that I think we
just have to sort of look at this
globally and understand what's happening
so I just want us before we take some
questions I just wanted to switch it
over a bit more more to focus more on
sort of like that next step
from the from the journal to the rest of
the world like as stuff spreads out
through the news through the magazines
to newspapers online and so on our are
we sort of like on the outside of this
or dynamic do we have them like nothing
to do with it or we kind of are we are
we part of the problem we get to the
solution later but are we are we part of
the problem yeah we we journalists we
journalists yeah so some journalists
first and then the sighs its connection
of anything yeah sure
many of us are clickbait chasers many of
us our publishing the latest headline
many of us are we're gonna look for that
paper with the flashiest play yeah it
happens I'd be lying if I said it didn't
how do we approach it those of us who
have the privilege of you know in the
case of Scientific American let me put
that that head-on as editor-in-chief
there one of the first things I did when
I became editor-in-chief of Scientific
American and a half a dozen years ago
was instead of having the scientists
write more in that received wisdom kind
of way which I was describing earlier
applied to education but we used to have
size so one of the things I should have
said earlier in case people don't know
is about half maybe more of the feature
articles in Scientific American are
written by scientists they're written in
collaboration with our journalists so
that they're accessible but they're
they're written by scientists about
their work and in the past we used to
let the scientists write in kind of a
lecture style as if everything was
solved and it would look over the past
three four years and and it kind of came
out like here's all the received wisdom
a thing that I tried to do and I think
is an example of I like to think I hope
to think a productive way to approach it
is tell us your story
as if it's what I did last summer what
was your question how did you try to
explore it when you made a mistake what
happened there how did you get past it
who did you talk to and so I actually
invited the researchers and increasingly
we do this in Scientific American to
speak from a first-person point of view
about them in their tea
and embrace the fact that science is
meandering that we do make mistakes that
sometimes we see things in the data that
because of confirmation bias or a
mistake in the reagent or or counterfeit
you know technology that we bought that
we didn't know these things happen
because it is a product of human
endeavor but because science is a
process and an evidence-based one
eventually we write that over time you
know meaning we write in the sense of
righ dear Ellen write it down and so I
think that's one way we can contribute
take the longer view don't just be
slavish to the thing that maybe just
happen that's the sharp headline but try
to provide the context and I think
that's one place where at least the
journalism world that we participate in
we can benefit this process private yeah
I mean about sort of you know creating a
retraction watch what made us want to do
that and I think one of the answers that
I could also give is that we wanted to
write about that process of science you
know I I have to say and so I was at
Reuters health I was running Reuters
health at the time Reuters I'm sure you
all know is a large wire service and
Reuters survives like most wire services
do on volume and our clients were very
clear about how much volume they wanted
and how do you write and I could give
you the numbers but it's somewhat
staggering I don't want to scare people
but how do you create that many stories
per week doing something other than
writing about every study that comes out
now I'd like to think that we and some
of us for a professional audience may be
a medical audience that understood that
but I and I like to think we put the
kind of context in that you would see it
like health news review which is a great
site that tells you you know gives ideas
about how to cover medical studies in
particular you know the sort of the COFF
the triad of coffee chocolate and red
wine right I think that if if no
reporter ever wrote a story about
chocolate coffee red wine again we all
be better off but the point is I
actually I wouldn't say I had whiplash a
little bit but I had a little of
cognitive dissonance because you're I
was in my day job running a website that
you know not a website had a wire
service that had to pump out the volume
and it was we were reporting on single
studies dozens of them every day and yet
I was sort of thinking trying
to think a little bit more globally in
slowing things down and thinking about
the experience of science and what it
all meant maybe that was useful actually
maybe it tried to sort of connected some
dots for me but I think that's I think
it would be great if more journalists
did the sort of work that Mariette was
describing which is and and which I
think this salon is very much about
which is about the how science really
works we all need to get excited about
what science is doing for us but how do
you really include at least some of them
well I just want to touch on that before
I let the scientists pass judgment on
those journalists is that like I think
when I became a fan of Attraction watch
and and then I started reading about
some of these people that were featured
there which you know there I started to
see more and more these longer pieces
about some of the more notorious
characters I it was hard to look away
because in the most extreme cases where
people would have to have like 2030
what's the record but for one person
having to be 83 X 183 papers from one
scientist time to be retracted and you
start reading about these people
and they're just like they're sociopaths
and and and fascinating and you're like
how did this person go years and years
and years lying to everyone around them
I mean and that's we love reading about
that is there a risk there that if you
that that we're gonna swap the sort of
naive idea of science scientists as hero
who is only about the truth gonna swap
that for you know scientists and
sociopaths trying to get the next grant
I mean is that a risk absolutely it is
and it's something that you know I
wouldn't say we thought of on day one
but that hit us sort of smacked us in
the face quarterly in the way that we
try and combat that if you will both in
our own minds and our own work but also
in terms of the public so I mean one
thing that has happened I don't know
that would surprise anyone to learn that
a lot of what I would sort of frankly
call anti science forces advocates have
seized upon what we do we're very
popular with them not all of them but
with some of them and so we're very
conscious of that one of the things that
we've done to try and combat that is to
create something called this gets back
to something Mary I was talking to
in terms of trying to correct director
is doing doing the right thing we have
it doing the right thing award we did we
create actually with stat oh it's Adam
and me and Adam and our column there
it's that we handed out the first one
just about a month ago and the idea
there is to reward people who do the
right thing by correcting the record at
some cost of themselves right because
say you know correctly record is great
very important but you actually may face
consequences if you do that and I think
we've talked about what some of those
points as it can be and we call it the
it's doing the right thing so it's
called the dirt award which is almost
sometimes you have to get dirty to clean
up the side their birthday but I think
that if you if you approach it and tell
those stories as well we really try and
tell those choices well I think you at
least over time can tell the whole
picture you know so so before we turn to
some questions just one here from the
scientists about what you've how you
feel the sort of the journalism world
fits into the issues that we've been
raising about you know the competition
the pressures and so on you know I mean
is that is the way that the journalism
is covering it kind of making things
worse or better I mean half what's
what's your perspective the preferred
answer of the scientist is I never said
that does the journalist made it up and
sometimes that does happen or you know
at least thought there is some some
major difference between what comes out
of my mouth and what comes in the
imprint more often what happens is the
scientists would say I know I said that
but I prefer that I didn't demanding to
see our articles in advance because I
just want to check my quotes good huh
maybe I said something I shouldn't know
there's that - I think that one of the
things that is changing the equation
well two of the things are changing
question is one as you know journalism
is now in you know its own interesting
situation I have friends or journalists
and it's not easy to find it you know
maintain a job as a journalist you've
got off often you're a freelancer that
means even more pressure even less time
to check stories even even more pressure
to go for those so for the sexy stuff
and all that so
once out of the equation the other side
is more and more young scientists
especially beginning with PhD students
and then postdocs and young
investigators on tenure-track they start
actually writing their own stuff they
write blogs
you know i-i've write two blogs so I
communicate directly to the public that
that's interesting because then I have
journalists who come to me and want to
talk about something that I published on
my blog not something in the published
department literature and so that I
think adds an interesting I mean I don't
know where that but it's going at the
moment wherever I kind of welcome it
because I do think that there is it's a
good thing to add the voices directly
are the scientists scientists should be
more conscious about talking to the
general public after all as you were
saying not only our education but most
of our money for research and science
what does come directly or indirectly
from taxpayers and so it's just right
that that we spent some of the time
talking back to those people and say hey
you know here's what what I doing and
why is it interesting so that's part
that is part I think of being scientists
and now it has been of course
historically this was a problem because
your colleagues will look at you and say
you're wasting your time either you're
wasting your time or you're not a good
enough scientist and that's what you're
doing that instead of another grant
proposal I think that's changing you
know
Planck famously said that the Max Planck
famously said that ideas in science get
accepted pick one funeral at a time
because the op4 die I mean that's true
also for other attitudes within science
that is the old the old guard is
retiring and then getting out of the way
and so the new people have grown up with
social networks and and and Twitter and
blog and things like that and I think
that actually is almost an unqualified
good at the moment we'll see how that
involves for the next decade I agree
completely I think that so I don't begin
to understand the constraints that a
journalist faces you know I have two
inches to describe something that took
someone six years and that when you have
to go from the boring details that make
it science and make it trustworthy and
pick out who this is the Wow right the
we call it the gee whiz stuff you lose
something and it can come out wrong and
I know that
when I've worked with journalists I
asked to see it to check the facts not
to check that I come off a certain way
or but but facts can change when you
change the structure of the sentence if
I if it takes me 20 words to say
something because I'm trying to be
really accurate and really precise and
not let it get blown out of proportion
and you have to trim it down to 6 then
it becomes a sentence that you know you
use the word proof I use the word I'll
say well I have evidence that it's not
this in its embassy you know and it
takes me yeah right and then that
becomes proof and now you have a
headline to write and now people think
that scientists prove things and that I
think is a is is difficult I don't know
what the answer is I accept a very deep
cultural shift and I hope things like
this festival will encourage it but
there was a time where you needed to
know science to be considered an
educated person and now you need to know
the humanities you know you you know I
don't like Shakespeare you know but I
think that you shouldn't be able to
avoid learning biology because you're an
English major I think that we have to go
back to a time where even if you do use
the word proof people understand what
that means in the context of science
they they can read that and say oh okay
what that means you know it's just it's
not automatic that they will interpret
that as we've we have a lot of evidence
that supports this idea so we're running
with it and if and if that was part of
our citizenship almost I think that
would that would help a great deal i I
don't know how to make it happen okay so
can we hard for me to see better could
we seal some questions oh there's a
oh we do have a microphone you pass that
all right so raise your hands high so
how about we start with that person okay
how much of this problem in
communicating about science might be due
to the fact that you have some people
some philosophers who would argue that
scientific truth is as relative a truth
as is simply as good as any other form
of truth I'm talking about the
relativist d constructionists I'd be
interested in hearing what the panel
would say well since I'm the resident
philosopher on the planet I think that
one right yeah yeah so there is an issue
with that but I really believe I'm not
usually an optimist but I believe that
that's done and over with pretty much
this was these four so-called science
Wars mostly they happened in the 1990s
there was is small but vocal set of post
modernist philosophers and sociologists
it wasn't just philosophers who started
going around saying well science is
socially constructed which of course is
true we were saying earlier you know
several times science is a social
enterprise it is socially constructed in
a sense in a sense in other sense of
course that social construction is done
independent of the outside world it's
very highly constrained by the outside
world the response to that sort of
extreme version of post-modernism
actually came both from scientists Allen
so call here at NYU for instance and
especially by philosophers of science
the fathers of science were very strong
in responding to that to that sort of
extreme criticism of science and I think
actually we're in a good place at the
moment between the two disciplines
because there is a good balance where
the scientists themselves tend to
realize that yes that is in fact quite a
bit more of the human side to do in
science that is mistakes there is fraud
there is all sorts of stuff all right so
my question is to do with a topic which
was briefly touched upon which is
replicating research and that there are
no real incentives for that have
interview do you have any ideas about
how they might be incentives
to replicate studies perhaps work it
into the system we're just like a lot of
professors at university they required
to teach maybe graduate students are
required to replicate research before
moving on to original stuff just that I
I want to qualify that there's no
incentive no incentive to replicate
often so all results are comparisons
you're always comparing what you got to
something else and in many cases what
you're comparing to is what the last guy
got so you're replicating it as one of
your controls so it does happen what you
suggest is a great idea and one way of
teaching and getting your students kind
of up to whatever boundary you're
pushing is to have them replicate what's
been done you that's how you can learn a
technique that's how you can really
understand what what the person you're
your competitor found do you agree with
it do don't you agree with it and and
you can use that as a teaching tool so
there's ways of sneaking it in the you
can't just publish a paper where you
replicate what everybody else did but
often you can include the replication as
that which you are building upon so
here's where we started yes we agree but
now look at this and so I think that
it's it's not as clear-cut as we we have
no incentive to replicate I think it's
it's you can use it I think to victims
are too quick opposite sides of the same
coin maybe um one is that I I would
argue in it gets back to something
Massimo was saying earlier that I would
actually argue that some people have
made their careers or starting to in
this case I think things are changing
not so much in replicating but actually
failing to replicate now that creates
its own sort of bias because if you
become known as the person who always
goes out and fails to replicate then you
kind of show up to the
saloon with a you know a couple of guns
or something six-shooters but so that's
but that there there can be a sort of
incentive of its own to do that and the
other is probably talking under the
other side of my mouth that when I was
talking earlier about we have too many
metrics well if we're gonna be stuck
with metrics well we could make this
into a metric you could have something
Adam and I reckon you know sort of at a
very high level called for a bunch of
years ago a transparency index like you
know out of a given Journal out of a
given maybe lab at a given sort of field
what are the what is the likelihood that
that's that something actually holds up
and if you turn that into a positive and
if you say well the higher it is the
better then maybe you'll have something
that stays but again those are not
particularly well formed ideas I mean
what about I mean on the journalism side
I mean what could we do to sort of let
people know that that one little crazy
sounding paper in science is you know
may not be the last word you know turned
out that was wrong that big article we
wrote know you know or I mean how do we
sort of build in that process of
replication into the journalism about
science I mean maybe I'm gonna sound
like a broken record at this point
because part of what we do when we
choose what we cover is we celebrate
things in effect right because we we've
chosen that we've lovely glue curated a
story and presented it I think one way
we do that is is we portray the lives of
scientists we portray the what is it
like in a lab the times they used to
have a piece that I loved a lot which
was about working life of scientists and
I've had many researchers tell me that
you know you have no idea how long I
spent writing this software program so I
could do this piece of research on
cosmology it's all of that that we
should celebrate as well not just the
result that pops out so yeah that's one
way we could contribute so we're talking
a little bit about the discussion
section in experiments and how that's
really just not the science of it and
yet it's most interesting part so I'm a
philosophy student and a lot of what we
do when I'm in classes doing research is
we look at the discussion section in
science
pieces and so I'm not really reading the
rest of the experiment or I am but like
briefly I'm looking at what their
conclusion was and what they're
discussing um so really should we be
taking a lot out of that and like
writing our own papers off of it or
should we just be looking at the
experiment side oh wow that's a great
question um this discussion section is
part of the science the it's it's the
most educated mind at that point
the person who did the work and got
those results at that moment that is the
most educated guess and it's often you
develop experience you develop you know
you learn as you go
so it's certainly part of the science
and the interpretation is very
interesting and putting it in context is
very interesting but I would say that
you might be able to put a layer of
depth into your understanding of how we
got to that if you look at the results
if you look at the part that is just
here is what we got and I and then say I
think you know the process that we go
through okay
how many different ways could I have
gotten this same thing and then you go
through and then you go in the
discussion and you say well I might have
gotten it if a was true but I could also
gotten it if B was true and that process
of forcing yourself to not fall in love
with one interpretation the the danger
of falling in love with an idea and we
do we fall in love with our ideas it's
very creative
and it's and I think that if you were to
go and look at the difference between
what's in the results section where they
say this is what happened and how that
gets turned into a discussion section
where there's the philosophical
underpinnings of it where you're
thinking about necessity and sufficiency
and you're thinking about all those
those very basic intellectual processes
that are behind it I think that you
might get something different and very
interesting comparing the you know
the facts ma'am - here's how I interpret
this and here's what I think is
important about it I think that'd be an
interesting way to look at it but there
is an additional problem there right so
there's a method problem if you will
which is scientific papers are in a
sense piece of fiction well some of them
really are fiction and but all of them
to some extent are in fact pieces
fiction in the sense that it really
didn't happen like that did this is near
the structure of this of the paper is
incredibly artificial there's this
introduction first of all you don't even
do that you've read in third person
they did we did write passive voice so
it's like that's changing fortunately so
it's it's like you're supposed to be
distancing yourself as much as possible
right and so this is very structured
thing the introduction materials and
methods the results in the conclusion
and the discussion and they're supposed
to have these really different functions
as if you sort of pretending that when
you write the introduction you really
don't know at that point how things are
gonna turn out but of course you've
wrote the introduction after you've done
the experiment after you done the data
analysis in fact typically the way I use
I don't know how other people do it but
the way I taught my students to write
the papers was never to start with the
introduction you always start with the
results because you want to have the
results in good shape and you know the
the by grams the tables and all that
after you've done that then you sort of
write you write the price to the actual
narrative that goes with the results
then maybe you come back to a little bit
of introduction discussion then you go
back and forth and until everything fits
together so it's a work of fiction it's
everything is put in a way that it's not
the weight actually what I don't mean if
we're efficient in the way that you are
obviously that problematic one but it
does give the impression even to the
scientists themselves that there is a
lot more objectivity a lot more rigor a
lot more sort of well it had to be that
way then there really is science is much
more fun than that but it's much more
unpredictable imagine if you were
actually running a scientific paper the
way in which you write a novel or a
little you know short stories like oh so
we started out this way we were having
coffee that morning with my graduate
student and he said you know damn them
we don't understand this way that would
be much more true
to the way things actually happen I'm
not suggesting that's practical but you
know but you need to keep it in mind
that when you read a scientific paper
there is a lot of rearranging of stuff
going I interview somebody for an
article I'm always just I just kind of
like set the paper aside be like okay
come on how did this really happen
exactly and you get a bizarre story that
you never would have guessed for me in
the paper much more interesting yes I
just like to thank everybody for
attending today so thank you all for
coming
[Applause]
[Music]